[Music]
well never did I think that the guy who
made Schindler's List would be in a row
over racism but unless you've been
living under a rock for the past week
then no doubt you've seen a lot of
backlash around Liam Neeson what's worse
is this guy is supposed to be promoting
his new movie cold pursuit but it looks
like it's going to be pretty cold at the
box office like I don't know if that's a
phrase or whatever but yeah you don't
come here for the jokes you come here
for the informative news
anyway Neeson earlier this week when
promoting his new revenge thriller gave
a bit too much information away when he
for some reason told the interviewer
that he wanted to kill a black person
any black person yes even you Will Smith
after his friend was raped by a black
man the comment came forth when talking
about the film which is about a father
getting revenge for his murdered son but
it's pretty much shocked a lot of people
even in the context of that originally
in an interview with the independent
Neeson said god forbid you've ever had a
member of your family hurt under
criminal conditions I'll tell you a
story this is true don't tell them
please anyway the actor went on to say
she handled the situation of the rape in
the most extraordinary way but my
immediate reaction was I asked did she
know who it was no what color were they
she said it was a black person I went up
and down areas with the cosh hoping I'd
be approached by someone I'm ashamed to
say that and I did it for maybe a week
hoping that some I don't even want to
say this bit it's a racist him would
come out of a pub and have a go at me
about something you know so that I could
kill him hmm obviously the Internet has
been in uproar with comments coming from
all over the place Frederick Joseph said
Liam Neeson being ready to take any
black life over what one person
allegedly did just shows how meaningless
and inconsequential black lives autism
even him telling the story demonstrates
a level of privilege and understanding
that there may not be repercussions
Phillip Henry says what's most
disturbing about what Liam Neeson said
is everything
but what's particularly terrifying is
the idea that the death of any other
black guy would satisfy the revenge
quota to the clear indication is that he
knows his whiteness would protect if he
followed through on it in case you can't
read this safe place says being upset
someone attacked your family is
understandable but targeting innocent
black men for a week with weapon when he
didn't even know who did it is racist do
you know how many innocent black people
have lost their lives in the past for
stuff like this this is not OK
it's kind of hard to argue with this but
Neeson has fought back telling ABC that
he's not racist and that he actually
wants to start a wider debate on racism
ah so that's what it was he's just like
Schindler in a way now I think about it
anyway there's also people on the other
side who jump to Liam's defense
including the very articulate John
Barnes who had this to say Liam Neeson
was talking about his film revenge and
he's talking about revenge doesn't do
anyone any good he mentions the fact
that being brought up in northern our he
understands how destructive that can be
he went on to tell a story of a
situation where by a friend of his had
been raped now if you listen to
everything he's talking about
he's talking about in the moment and you
can't blame him Liam Neeson for thinking
what he feels because this is what and
this is a while ago this is what society
has shown him that black people do
Muslims do this is what society is
wrongly showing him this is what the
media have wrongly portrayed to him so
in that moment he said for a week he was
going around looking to kill a black
person or a black and he did that in
quotation marks now what he actually
went on to say is what he was ashamed
and horrified by the way he felt yes
he's not ashamed and horrified and
wanted to commit them the act of revenge
he's ashamed and horrified because that
is what he thought about all black
people after a week he realized he was
wrong that is what he said I'm ashamed
and horrified of the way I felt now
depending on how you want to spin this
story now it's about he was going to
kill a black person what we want to
eventually what I think what I did we
don't want to spin it I beg your pardon
I say we don't want to spin it we want
to think about it and ventilated it's an
important subject no no no no no it's
been spun it's been spun because if you
want to think about what he's actually
saying the context which is why he then
said to the lady
he said to the lady in his voice I got a
particular set of skills if you don't
report this in the way that it is meant
now we're talking about and he
threatened to kill the woman what he's
actually saying is that he's horrified
and ashamed of the way he felt he went
on to say that that is exactly what he
went on to say which meant that he was
ashamed of the way he felt but you
cannot blame him for thinking that
because I said earlier with the whole
Raheem Sterling talking about influence
the media has you cannot blame people
but thinking Muslims because of Muslim
grooming gangs Jamaica arrogance then
look at Muslims and Jamaicans in a
negative light and he's admitting that
that is the way he viewed it so for this
one black person who raped this woman he
then looked at it from the perspective
of all black people are racists now what
he's actually saying is that this is
what I thought this is what I saw and I
am ashamed and horrified and after a
week I said to myself what am i doing
that is flat me the reality behind it as
much as people are now jumping on this
bandwagon of how terrible it is what
he's done he's come out and he's told
the truth overall it's a bit crazy at
the moment right now and I kind of feel
bad for the studio who have to still
promote a movie and make money after
this oh wait I've just seen its lines
gay you always put fake copyright claims
in on my video so I tell you what Sodom
naturally they pulled the star-studded
red carpet event and the movie looks
like it could either bomb or be a big
hit with the KKK obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the entire
situation and what you think will happen
to the movie because of this will
Netflix pick it up will Neeson act again
does the internet just love being
offended comment below and let me know
and if you enjoyed this video then make
sure you check out my breakdown of this
week's other big movie the lego movie -
which will be linked at the end this is
a channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]